welcome to this video playing grandmas
alexander red ski with an indian flag
that's weird india ah ok ok i think
isn't the drill juniors in india yeah i
think this is the case ok we get the
Kings gambit and uh I really I wanted to
study this this this line with Bishop e7
that recently was recommended the victor
boo Logan and his new black weapons book
but I only know that this is existing
but I don't know anything more ok
probably I should take it this was the
whole idea of the thing but what now hmm
what now what a weird position am that
the Kings gambit it will never ever be a
normal position now I mean taking at
night f6 that does not look right really
but what else Queen f6 knight c6 thus
the special perm the serb horn is
hanging taking a night f6 looks wrong
and i don't know i came i cannot
reinvent this opening over the bought
him it feels wrong to let him take here
really no probably not a good idea I
should have played something that I know
it's not like I have no opening against
the key i have no line against the Kings
gambit but this is something that i
found interesting and wanted to want it
to investigate check okay let's at least
try to play quick am
maybe I can put the night on g4 Bishop
d7 and chat and then go form I'm long
castles Queen f6 there is 95 fear not
good okay if I if he goes Bishop e2 and
h5 he can even take their multiple times
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
takes takes on h8 Kingda 7 8 i'm a piece
down yeah brilliant okay so let's do
this the whole thing is still totally
murky so it's not like I'm totally
totally lost here well maybe for a
computer but in a in a real-life game
the whole thing is still still really
really weird Queen f6 yeah there's
always this 95 move that is so is really
irritating so he takes hmm that
surprises me i thought that it isn't a
good idea to lose this this time but
maybe I'm wrong
and there are some some glee as tricks
Queen F 695 Quincy 693 C 7 check king d
8 90 x 90 3 at the end with a double
attack Queen f6 we can nom 9526 this is
with the temple I'm going to do that no
use no use and spending more time m 97
kindy 89 88 I have 93 with made on g2
and attack on the Queen it's difficult
to even cover the mate really queen and
the raw eggs on on age 7 this is an
additional thing Bishop takes g4 Bishop
takes g-form yeah let let me think about
it Queen takes us useless so I have to
take him Queen takes Queen takes check
yeah that's not that's not a problem
check that's not a problem it's
essentially a double attack one on
various things the bishop and term and
also the pawn ham so if i take now or is
there a better move take here
like we should be three coming and I
have seven hangs ok I have to play this
first so that after Bishop move i'm
actually attacking g3
yeah GG 394 should be possible yes I
take now Bishop e3 is no other solution
right I have to do that Bishop e3 I can
even take a form okay not a huge choice
anyway take you four and then you can
give a ton of checks but am i checkmated
now I don't see it
check rookie 17 be five asif one he's
got c4 ah yeah yeah I am I morning ok
here it takes what she said no what
it takes his samne again here if I of c4
nah what is stupid loss I mean this is
just a stupid loss completely
unnecessary yeah I can just take c7 it's
not doing it and droop c8 I cannot
really do anything against that I am
check
check
check yeah eight seconds yeah okay come
on I mean it's it's also just less
resins yeah well how unnecessary can you
lose I mean this I cannot really believe
anything of that okay so it turns out
that the computer likes white because of
rook h5 what a move okay look aged five
but I cannot believe that this should be
really great can print that's very
surprising if there should be some
solution to to keep keep this equal 96
takes check Kim dat hmm now okay this is
this is equal I get you fall back and I
mean somehow I had the feeling that
there should be some solution here round
here of course that before I it's it's
not a good idea to play a line in the
King's gambit that you only know that
it's that it is existing yeah I don't
know cat I would need to look at this is
definitely a very fishy position I mean
cat the problem is that on the dark
squares I mean in very bad shape and I I
need some time before I get cancelled
and as we had seen one problem was that
I relied on h5 here this position which
is of course not not at all working you
can just check Winnie easily so i had to
give up the porn but i thought this
shouldn't be that bad but you know what
the real problem is the problem is that
the
has this hema me yeah of course I did
not see that at all coming typical
computer move it okay first I cannot
take it I mean maybe I need to but Chad
losers yeah banking on this this thing
very very weird stuff and I have no
movie threatening rook g5 even it's
really great and my great tricks like
this I mean they only work they only
work with the night already away so oops
Wow yeah so so cool stuff look H 5pm but
ok he played this human move and then I
really thought I should be out of out of
the woods which is essentially true but
it required precision and this is just
losing hey yeah i was thinking that i
can go here actually can i I'd
overlooked see for Jack yeah me i am not
good by the way what is this guy doing
with this this this bad rating here as a
grandmaster let's not fair ok so how
lost here in the King's gambit thanks
for watching